Штурмова бригада Нацгвардії "Буревій" є частиною "Гвардії наступу",
сформованої міністерством внутрішніх справ України для зміцнення ЗСУ.
Ця бригада постала на базі 1-ї бригади оперативного призначення Нацгвардії України.
Всі 9 бригад "Гвардії наступу" створені на базі підрозділів,
що вже мають бойовий досвід. Вони додатково укомплектовані новобранцями.
У перші дні літа на полігон для вишколу виїхав батальйон оперативного призначення
імені генерала Сергія Кульчицького, що нещодавно увійшов до складу бригади "Буревій".
На занятті відпрацьовували стрільбу з різних положень, з укриття,
зміну магазинів, а також стрільбу у двійках зі зміною положень, зміною укриттів.
Кулеметників тренують використовувати рух і рельєф місцевості для ефективного знищення ворога
й захисту власного життя. Інструктор оцінив виконання завдань на "четвірку".
Якщо ти кулеметник - ти пріоритетна ціль на полу бою.
І, звичайно, противник буде зосереджувати по тобі вогонь,
і треба бути підготовленим фізично, морально, і ти маєш швидко й вчасно змінювати свою позицію.
Тобто, ти відпрацював - будь добрий, міняй позицію, якщо не хочеш загинути.
Під час навчань нещадно палить сонце,
температура вище 30 градусів.
Але бійці мусять і далі тренуватися в повному спорядженні.
Інструктори вимогливі й карають промахи присіданнями й віджиманнями.
Ми не прицілюємося в "яблучко".
В динаміці щоразу намагаємося напрацьовувати дедалі більшу точність.
Ті, хто розуміє, про що йдеться, той знає, що в динаміці не так просто стріляти
під час перебіжок. А так тільки одне - прагнемо весь час до кращого.
Інструктори, що тренують "Гвардію наступу", пройшли підготовку в НАТО,
де закордонні спеціалісти навчали їх тонкощам військової справи.
"Дідівщини" на полігоні не помітно.
Особовий склад складається з більшості досвідчених бійців.
Але до нас дуже багато приходить новобранців,
які бажають проходити службу в нашій бригаді, в нашому підрозділі.
Вони стають в один стрій з нашими старими воїнами,
і розпочинають процес підготовки. І підтягуються.
Інструктори пройшли підготовку в НАТО,
дуже багато закордонних відряджень особового складу, де їх спеціалісти НАТО підготовлюють, на їхній техніці,
на нашій техніці й озброєнні.
Це все акумулюється в досвід і переноситься сюди, на поле бою.
У нас як такої проблематики "молоді" чи "старі" бійці взагалі немає.
"Старші" вчать "молодших". Ми в них теж можемо чогось навчитися.
Коли є вільна година, "старики" починають розказувати і показувати,
як наприклад, тепловізором користуватися, як користуватися іншими приладами.
Дають поради, розповідають про свій бойовий досвід.
Всього інструктори навчити не можуть, бо в такі терміни це нереально.
Бригада "Буревій" є штурмовою.
Одне з її головних завдань - прорив оброни ворога.
Тому бійців навчають поводженню з різноманітними видами зброї.
На цьому занятті був вишкіл зі стрільби з підствольних та ручних гранатометів.
Тим часом на іншому полігоні відпрацьовували навички бригадні артилеристи.
У них на озброєнні - НАТОвські гаубиці.
"Торнадо" прийшов у бригаду "Буревій" з тероборони ЗСУ і не шкодує про цей крок.
З того, що я бачив у "Гвардії наступу", де я маю честь служити народу України зараз,
це кадрові військові, які набагато краще нас навчають.
За той час що я тут, нас навчали з дуже різних сторін.
Артилерійське й інженерне забезпечення артилерійських підрозділів, будова гармат…
Ми їх розбирали і збирали, проходили курс базовий, але різносторонній.
Кожен день у нас є графік навчання, і кожен день ми навчаємося,
а після навчання в нас є практичні заняття.
Бойовий медик Іван перший рік повномасштабної війни залишався в тиловому підрозділі.
Але зрештою перевівся до батальйону ім. Кульчицького.
Бо це бойовий батальйон, який виконує бойові задачі на сході, на півдні.
Я для себе вирішив, що відсиджуватися в тилу - то трошки не моє.
Треба взяти участь у бойових діях у складі підрозділу, який, як бачите, навчається.
У нас відбуваються регулярні навчання, нас вчать,
ми не сидимо на позиції і чогось чекаємо.
Я розумію, що рано чи пізно все одно доведеться їхати захищати неньку Україну.
Я для того собі обрав варіант навчання, щоби мати більше знань і їхати на фронт з бойовими хлопцями.
У нас є іструктори, підготовлені за НАТОвськими стандартами,
і вони нам вже передають свій досвід.
Завдання Івана - евакуація поранених з поля бою і передача їх парамедикам.
Водночас він є таким же бійцем, як і решта,
опановує навички володіння стрілецькою зброєю.
Одна з функцій бойового медика - стежити, щоб у всіх бійців були індивідуальні аптечки.
Вони укомплектовані за НАТОвським протоколом MERCH.
Турнікет. Вдягається на кінцівки для зупинки кровотечі.
Оклюзійні наліпки. Заклеюють дірку в легенях.
Бинт стерильний. Використовується для тампонади ран або перев'язки.
Так званий "ізраїльський бандаж". Дуже зручна штука коли ти затампонував бинтом рану, тобі треба це зафіксувати.
Одноразові рукавички. Гемостатик перев'язувальний. Зупиняє кровотечу.
Він працює так: намокає, розбухає і заклеює, умовно кажучи, рану.
Термоковдра. Обов'язково, коли людина втрачає кров, треба забезпечити їй тепло.
Тут у нас є спеціальні ножиці, якими ми зрізаємо одяг для того,
щоб краще нам бачити, яка травма, де вона, характер тієї травми тощо.
Досвідчені бійці батальйону імені Кульчицького кажуть,
що раніше в них була спеціалізація на бойових дій у лісах та містах.
Нині вони відпрацьовують вміння воювати на відкритих ділянках місцевості,
взаємодіяти з дронами і навчаються навичкам володіння зброєю важкої піхоти.
Але командир батальйону "Чорний" заявив,
що головним для кожного бійця-добровольця є бойовий настрій
і розуміння того, хто є ворогом
і що робити для якнайшвидшого завершення війни.